hey everyone hope you're doing well in
today's video i'll be showing you my
wind down routine
so i'm gonna take you through what
happens after i finish work
up until i go to sleep granted my
routine has slight variations across
different days
and looks pretty different across the
seasons
but this is what i've settled on
recently so
maybe this is kind of like a winter wind
down routine
anyways i hope you enjoy so the first
part of our wind down routine involves
walking the dogs because the sun sets at
around like
4 30 here-ish right and we need to take
him out before
it's dark because we got coyotes in our
neighborhood
like much of san diego so it's actually
kind of dangerous to go out
[Music]
i'm gonna open up the pizza scott take a
break from cyberpunk
i guess
[Music]
oh it does smell really good
rogue rogue tapatio in the mix what time
is it
6 30. we're done watching we're done
eating dinner and
we've watched about four episodes of tv
it's not even 7 p.m
watch two episodes of tv really
we watched one episode of kim's and one
episode of shit's creep oh
two episodes how many did i say four
we just tend to do everything very early
in the winter because there's nothing to
do
it's dark it's dark
so a really important part of my wind
down routine
is of course going to sleep and
therefore it's really important that i
have a comfortable
like bed set up in order to do so which
is where i wanted to thank the sponsor
of today's video
helix ellie do you like the helix
mattress too you sleep on it every night
huh
we first got helix's dusk luxe matrix
in the queen size for our guest room but
we had my brother stayed there for a
little bit
and we've like taken naps in there and
the mattress was just
so nice like luxury bed feeling we
really wanted to replace our main
mattress
and so we did scott and i took the quiz
again to figure out which mattress fits
best for us which is one of the best
parts about the helix service
and we again got mesh with the dusk luxe
mattress this time in cal king because
you know
it with two medium large sized dogs in
the bed
it actually doesn't leave very much room
for us but
all of us all four of us plus the cat
really enjoy sleeping on it
helix knows that everybody sleeps
differently whether you're a back
sleeper or you're a side sleeper
and what preference you have for the
mattress firmness and so their sleep
quiz has been actually really accurate
for us
in matching us with the kind of mattress
that we enjoy i'm typically like a back
and side sleeper
and scott is kind of more like a side
sleeper
and we both kind of enjoy like a firm
mattress but not something that feels
super
rock hard and so the mattress we got has
been perfect for our needs
the mattress that we had before this one
was also like it came in a box and it
expanded over time
but this one just feels a lot better i
think because
of the way that the mattress is filled
on the inside
it feels honestly like a regular like
coil mattress bed and so it's super
comfortable
the best part about the helix mattress
is that it gets shipped right to your
door for free
it comes in a box and it's super easy to
set up and in case you're nervous about
buying something that you haven't tried
before
they have a 100 night sleep trial so you
basically get three months to try out a
mattress and really try it to figure out
if you love it or not
and if you don't love it then they'll
pick it up for you and you'll get the
free refund so if you're interested then
check out the helix mattress by going to
the link in the description box down
below
you'll get up to 200 off and two free
pillows
thank you again helix for sponsoring and
i'm honestly gonna start getting ready
for bed
i don't know about you all but showering
in the winter is one of my least
favorite activities but i've been taking
care of
all of my skin and hair because it's
been so dry in san diego like
the humidity level yesterday was like
seven percent so i've been moisturizing
hella i have been using this
it's got like hyaluronic acid and then i
also use this the sarah v
facial moisturizing lotion for
the evening to restore the protective
skin barrier
and i realized that wasn't enough
because my face would still just get
so bumpy and dry that
i reintroduced this one this is the
all-in-one essence the organic one
from muji i had the bigger one when i
ran out and muji is not doing so well in
the u.s so i'm waiting for my mom to
send me
a new bottle but in the meantime i've
got this travel size kit
just been using some regular like lotion
from vaseline for my skin
i've been using this one the uribe super
shine moisturizing cream for my hair
because even my
hair is super dry you put a japanese
girl in california
in november and she will just shrivel up
i tell ya
so gotta protect all of everything
or else i will just turn into like dried
squids
[Music]
so
all right fam so it's 10 57 pm
i'm pretty tired so i'm gonna go to bed
if you like this video then make sure to
subscribe and if you'd like to see
a get ready for the day video like
basically the opposite of that
then let me know in the comments anyways
i hope you enjoyed this realistic
possibly a little bit rough around the
edges video
about how i wind down and i will see you
all soon
[Music]
bye
you